let's get started now with our first
question David from your vantage point
what's different in today's competitive
landscape compared to years ago well
first of all great to be with you today
we've had a lot of fun in the prelims
here what's different about today's
landscape an awful lot the power of
stakeholders is much more pronounced
than it has ever been before the media
landscape has radically changed
globalization new technologies all of
these forces are at work that really
change the competitive landscape for
companies all around the world and how
has this new media landscape changed the
challenges facing current organizations
oh my goodness you know if you think
back to how media has changed just in
the last decade or two the fragmentation
of media people have many more sources
of information and actually
disinformation misinformation the the
attention span of individuals is been
reduced there's information overload
people trying to figure out what is true
what is not true their barrage with
information the other issue is that this
new media landscape provides people even
small numbers of people a
disproportionate voice compared to their
actual numbers so that their reach is
far more extended than in traditional
media in the traditional media world of
yesterday and how did interest groups
develop such power politically such that
they are so formidable a force within
business yeah I think you've got to
unravel history a little bit to
understand how that has happened and
I'll give you a couple of examples in
the early 60s of Ralph Nader I wrote a
book called unsafe at any speed and it
was an indictment of the
'mobile industries safety practices and
that spurred a movement of consumers
being much more demanding as to the
quality of products that they were going
to be using that then morphed into from
a movement into consumer rights and that
morphed into regulation legislation and
you can actually plot many of today's
large stakeholder interests
environmental for example in the late
60s there were a number of events that I
would call triggering events that
created the environmental movement of
the the Cuyahoga River which is outside
Cleveland actually caught fire and it
was a huge news story at the same time
or maybe just before there was a big oil
spill off of California and Santa
Barbara these kinds of events galvanized
public opinion and it created a movement
that ultimately galvanized Earth Day in
1970 consequently this was during the
Nixon administration of regulation and
legislation followed the creation of the
EPA followed all of the environmental
regulations that companies have to deal
with really trace back to those days and
you can follow these kinds of
stakeholder movements pretty much across
the board whether it's civil rights
consumer rights environmental rights gay
rights you name it they all trace back
to you know a triggering event that
created movement and so forth and I
think companies are well served to
understand some of the history of how
these forces have evolved because that
will inform how you deal with them
mm-hmm so is there a system or approach
for how to calibrate the risks created
by non market forces
well there is risk is is a complicated
subject but in simple terms of the first
step is
to understand your risk profile whether
it's your business risk reputational
risk those kinds of risks that your
company may encounter then once you have
assessed what all of these risks are you
have to prioritize them which are the
really important risks which are the
ones that would if they came to pass
would they be really important or really
detrimental to your company and then you
have to come up with strategies to
mitigate those risks here at Stanford I
remember when I first got here one of
the things that I tried to do was
evaluate the risk profile of the
university where were the big
reputational risks around the around the
university and you know I would I had
the luxury of working with some
incredible people here one of whom was
Dean peizo this the Dean of the medical
school who was doing a lot of work to
make sure that the the work that was
done in the medical school would stand
up to any kind of scrutiny so that
relationships with companies were
carefully disclosed and managed properly
that's you know an example of
identifying a risk prioritizing the risk
and then mitigating the risk I love that
and you've worked across many different
sectors politics government business
academia are beyond strategy market are
beyond market strategies different from
sector to sector well I've had a pretty
varied career you're right the sectors
that I've worked in as you mentioned
politics and government and corporate
and and now academia there are some
commonalities and there are some
differences a lot of the public affairs
tried-and-true rules of the road seem to
transcend sectors and I think that's one
of the things that I've really enjoyed
about my career is that I've been able
to have kind of a bird's-eye view of all
of these sectors and try to identify
some of the things that are common to
all and then some of the differences you
know there's a big difference to what a
government
entity is facing compared to a
corporation and understanding those
differences are really important and how
do you feel that societal expectations
of companies have changed in regard to
non market issues well I mean all of us
as consumers certainly have a higher
standard for the kinds of products and
services that we avail ourselves of and
there are a lot more tools to compare
and contrast products and services
across a particular business category
but beyond that if take a look at
employees employees are a key
stakeholder group of any company right
you know
stakeholders of a company include
investors and consumers and customers
and and employees well employees have in
today's world are much more interested
in what does their company stand for and
so you're seeing employee pressure put
on company leadership just take stands
on issues that maybe twenty years ago a
company wouldn't feel that was an
appropriate thing to do so really
understanding your employee base and
whether or not you're going to get the
right employees or the best employees to
work for you you have to understand what
their needs wants and aspirations are
and stakeholder power seems to have
become even more intense how do you feel
this has happened well you look at how
stakeholders are able to mobilize today
and a lot of that has to do with new
media platforms the internet actually
provides a lot of tools for stakeholders
to communicate globally so that if
there's an issue that is of importance
to a certain stakeholder group they're
able to connect with others that have
the same interests as they have and by
doing that they can exert pressure on a
company they can mobilize
is both in a positive way and in a
negative way I think that's one of the
interests interesting things about the
Internet is that you know there's a kind
of a paradoxical nature of the Internet
that it it you know on the one hand kind
of democratizes information it provides
a platform so that so many people around
the world can understand things that
they might not have even confronted
before you take something like Darfur
the tragedy of Darfur in the Sudan you
know before the internet maybe people
would never have heard of that but
because of the internet that was a issue
that was brought to the public
consciousness and you know that was a
helpful thing by the same token the
internet also provides a platform for
bad actors and we've seen that play out
in a number of ways so you know when you
when you talk about how new technologies
intersect with stakeholders there is a
symbiotic relationship between the two
stakeholder power has been I think
enhanced by new technologies mm-hmm so
we're gonna switch gears a little bit
and talk about brand management so
everyone is talking about brand
management in the beyond market world
how do you feel that branding plays out
well I look I look at brand a little
differently than some in that the first
step that I go through in terms of
trying to understand you know brand as a
constant construct is to whom am I
making a promise I see brand as a
promise and all organizations have
multiple stakeholders you look at
Stanford Stanford has you know students
obviously faculty employees the
community the federal government we do a
billion dollars worth of federal
research here you would think that the
government wants us to do that well so
they are a stakeholder right donors now
to all of those stakeholders we make
either an explicit or an implicit
promise
so to a student it might be you know
you're gonna get a world-class education
to that students parent it might be
slightly different your son or daughter
is gonna get a world-class education but
in a safe environment because the safety
issues is of paramount concern to
parents that is not exactly the same
promise we might make to a donor a donor
wants to know that their dollars that
they provide to Stanford that those
dollars are going to be used wisely
that we're gonna be a good financial
steward so really digging down into what
are the promises that are made that all
roll up to what is the Stanford brand is
an important methodology I think to go
through now the interesting thing for me
because I've live in a world of
reputation management is what's the
relationship between brand and
reputation well I think there's a pretty
direct correlation that to those to whom
a promise has been made reputation is
about whether that promise has been kept
so brand is a promise
reputation is about keeping that promise
and companies that understand the value
of reputation should be looking at what
are all those promises that they're
making all their stakeholders and how
are those promises being fulfilled or
are they falling short of any of those
problems I love that and what do you see
as the relationship between the
organization's brand and its reputation
well I think the the there are two sides
of the same coin really that reputation
is so important for what kind of
employees are you going to recruit what
kind of partners what kind of alliances
are you going to be able to make are you
going to be partnering with Tier one
partners or tier two partners are you
going to be the first or the last
company to be investigated
you know reputation as they say you
build by the drop but you lose it by the
bucket and you know so companies that
that
understand the value of reputation and
what it really means it's not a
platitude you got to live it those are
the companies that I think have the
competitive advantage going forward
interesting and how about crisis
management are the rules of crisis
management it's still the same as
they've been in the past yeah a lot of
them are and some of them are not I'll
give you an example of each there's an
old saw called the worst first and what
that really means is that when an
organization is subjected to some sort
of accusation or criticism that if
there's validity to it you get the worst
information out first because what that
means is that that story is more likely
to have a downward trajectory than an
upward trajectory the natural kind of
human behavior doesn't comport with that
because people want to hold back they
want to hope that this will quote blow
over and so they are reluctant to get
that worst information out first so that
the story will have that downward
trajectory what happens they put out
information piecemeal and then the story
becomes a two day or a three day or a
four day story those kinds of stories
are much more likely to have negative
impact than the story that is cauterized
immediately on the flip side and an
example of what's changed and I think
the worst first rule still generally
applies what's changed is because of
technology an old rule used to be don't
repeat the accusation if somebody calls
you a skunk don't say I deny that I am a
skunk well that was the old rule don't
say that you know you can describe why
you're not asked run skunk but you don't
use the word right well in today's world
the way people search for information
they're going to use the accusation
as their search tool so if you're if if
the information you put out on a on an
electronic platform doesn't contain
those search term that that that
phraseology they won't find your
response they won't find your
explanation and so you have to you have
to communicate on the platforms that
your adversaries are using and I think
that's the rule that if if people are if
you're seeing things on the net that are
troubling or damaging you've got to be
able to live in that world as well
interesting how do you see that values
play into crisis management well you
know if you think about this the speed
at which a crisis develops far faster
than it ever did before and so you may
not have all the information you would
like you may not know all the facts and
that might lead you to not respond you
know there's a natural tendency well we
don't have all the facts so we can't
really say anything well what you can
say is what your values are and what you
can talk about your values and that
whatever you do in response to a
particular crisis is going to be based
on the values of your organization or
your company companies that don't really
have clarity about their values and are
kind of coming up with them on the fly
they're at a tremendous disadvantage
conversely companies that have a very
clear sense of who they are what they
stand for even in the midst of crisis
they have competitive advantage so what
are some common features that you have
observed about how crises evolve and how
leaders have responded well it's a mixed
bag I think some leaders do a great job
managing crisis you know you go back to
the Johnson and Johnson famous case back
in the 80s
Jim Burke who was the chairman of the
board you know
with the tylenol case made a very
courageous decision that was based on
the values of his company and he got
great credit for that but had Johnson
and Johnson not known what its values
were he wouldn't have been able to make
the decisions that he made to take
tylenol off the shelves nationally and
do it in a way that was timely which is
also another issue okay interesting what
is the Iron Triangle and how does it
affect business strategies
well the Iron Triangle is really a term
of art that came to be about the
relationship between kind of the the
legislative branch in Washington the
bureaucracy on the executive side of the
coin and then interest groups and you
know it's generally not been perceived
as a very positive thing that there's
this sort of triangle of interest that
collude with each other to create a more
favorable environment for companies or
organizations that interact with it and
so it became a term of art probably
thirty years ago of this Iron Triangle
and now with more transparency you know
I think some of the issues that might
have existed years ago are you know a
little bit more in the light of day and
people can kind of understand a little
bit more of what forces are at work so
do you see any new paradigms for
managing stakeholder relationships well
I think that that if there's a paradigm
of that you know we could identify it is
how well do you understand your
stakeholders of your organization and
you know because remember people think
people don't do things for your reasons
they do things for their reasons and the
more you understand where they're coming
from the war you understand what are the
dynamics
forces at work that are causing them to
behave in a certain way the more you're
gonna be able to respond to that and
connect to that and build partnerships
as opposed to an adversarial
relationship okay and the first word in
the title of our new course is strategy
strategy beyond markets strategy is it
just today's buzzword or how would you
define it yeah it's an interesting term
you know strategy comes from the Greek
word Strategos and Strategos means a
general and tactics comes from the word
tactic toasts
which means arranged in order so it
tells you strategy is about big picture
and tactics are about kind of execution
when it comes to strategy being a
buzzword I don't think of strategy in
kind of a classic sense you know the
dictionary definition is you know it's a
methodology for achieving an objective
okay that's true
I think of strategy more as a process
that the first step in that process is
kind of a rigorous contextual
understanding you have to really
understand context because context is
the foundation of everything then you
move into okay what are your what are
your objectives then if you're trying to
achieve an objective whatever it is you
have to engage in something I would call
if then thinking so if I do this this
will happen if I do that that will
happen and the more steps you can follow
in that if then this if-then that if
then and take that to its logical
conclusion the more you're likely to
have revealed all the alternatives and
have the opportunity to select which is
the alternative that has the optimum
chance of or optimum probability of
success then you have to look at you
know what is my organization all about
you know do a little self-reflection
about my organization's capabilities its
vulnerabilities its strengths its
weaknesses all of those things I think
vine into a strategic process and
finally when confronted with a situation
you know we're all action-oriented
people right at least we hope that we
are and action-oriented people typically
when faced with a problem or a challenge
say to themselves
the first question okay what am I gonna
do I would argue that's the wrong first
question the right first question is
what do we know how well do we
understand this circumstance and the
more we understand the circumstance the
more we go through this process that I
was just describing the more ability we
will have to unearth you know effective
strategies I love that strategy as
process
[Music]